muy bien finalmente estamos listos para
expresar a la aproximación cuadrática de
una función de varias variables en su
forma vectorial y ya he escrito todo
esto por aquí verdad aquí tenemos una
función f que en realidad es la función
que queremos aproximar verdad aquí
tenemos el punto x0 y es 0 que es el
punto alrededor del cual queremos hacer
la aproximación de efe y finalmente
tengo esta expresión para q de x que no
es otra cosa más que la expresión
desarrollada de la aproximación
cuadrática verdad y solo por si a lo
mejor no recuerdas muy bien que implicó
qué significan cada uno de estos
términos en realidad aquí tenemos
nuestro término constante verdad el
término constante que simplemente
resulta de evaluar
efe en el punto que nos interesa luego
aquí tenemos los términos lineales
estos son los términos lineales y se les
llama lineales porque esencialmente
tenemos una constante multiplicando a la
variable verdad aquí también tenemos una
constante multiplicando a la variable y
finalmente es
términos de aquí son los términos
cuadráticas verdad y son términos
cuadráticas porque son multiplicaciones
de dos variables por ejemplo aquí
tendríamos x con xx con ye yé conger
verdad entonces esta es digamos la lo
que si lo que son cada uno de los
términos de nuestra fórmula de la
aproximación cuadrática verdad entonces
para poder empezar a vector izar digamos
esta expresión entonces vamos a ir
considerando algunas cosas por ejemplo
tenemos un vector variable que va a ser
el vector x coma
y lo estoy poniendo digamos así
remarcado para que se distinga el vector
de la coordenada verdad de hecho el
vector variable es el que tiene
coordenadas x ye y también vamos a tener
un vector constante x0 que lo estoy
poniendo como en negritas para
diferenciarlo de él de la componente x0
verdad desde hecho este vector tiene
componentes x 0 ig0 entonces nuestro
término constante y es muy fácil de
escribir porque simplemente tendríamos
que evaluar la función
en el vector x0 verdad es justamente el
que tiene componentes x 0 y 0 muy bien
ahora vamos a escribir la parte lineal
la parte lineal podemos ver que se ve
como un producto punto verdad de hecho
este producto punto se da por el vector
que tiene a las derivadas parciales por
supuesto estas evaluadas en el vector x0
verdad la derivada parcial de f con
respecto de x y la derivada parcial de f
con respecto de ye y ambas van evaluadas
en el vector x0 ese sería nuestro primer
vector y hacemos el producto punto con
el vector que tiene componentes x - x 0
y corto y componente o coordenada menos
10 0 verdad esta es la segunda
componente así se ve nuestro producto
punto que define a la parte lineal sin
embargo nosotros sabemos que esto se
puede expresar de forma vectorial porque
este vector que tenemos aquí es el
gradiente de nuestra función y
simplemente habrá que evaluarla
y evaluar el gradiente en el vector x0 y
hacemos el producto punto con el vector
x variable menos el vector x0 verdad
simplemente si hacemos la diferencia
componente a componente tenemos
justamente este de aquí verdad entonces
hasta aquí hemos podido digamos vector
izar digamos la parte la parte lineal y
la parte constante la pregunta
interesante es cómo vamos a poder vector
izar digamos la parte cuadrática de esta
expresión y en realidad no es muy
difícil y por eso es que hicimos los
vídeos anteriores sobre formas
cuadráticas porque si no nos damos
cuenta esto es una especie de forma
cuadrática en donde aquí tenemos ciertas
constantes verdad entonces vamos a poner
quién es la matriz que define a esta
forma cuadrática la matriz que define
esta forma cuadrática pues por un lado
sería en esta esquina un medio de f
x x verdad y aquí voy a obviar que estoy
evaluando en el vector x0 solo hay que
recordar que estamos evaluando en ese
punto verdad recordemos que las formas
cuadráticas son algo de la forma x
cuadrada más 2 b x x que hice porque
cuadrada verdad entonces en esta parte
tendremos a en esta parte tendremos c
que en este caso es un medio de la
segunda derivada de f con respecto de g
ambas veces verdad y digamos en estas
otras esquinas tenemos b pero en este
caso 2 b es la derivada de f con
respecto de x y luego con respecto de y
quiere decir que aquí debemos tener un
medio de la derivada de f con respecto
de x y luego con respecto de ella y
recordemos que aquí va exactamente lo
mismo verdad entonces aquí tenemos la
matriz que define esta parte cuadrática
de la expresión verdad y casi se parece
casi es la scj así es la matriz que sean
la verdad excepto por este medio que
lleva en cada una
los componentes bueno del lado derecho
tendremos que multiplicar por un vector
en este caso el vector sería el que
tiene componentes x menos x 0
x 0 y la otra componente sería menos de
y por supuesto hay que multiplicar de
este otro lado por el mismo vector
verdad solo que ahora vamos a poner a
ese vector digamos de forma horizontal
verdad es es el vector transpuesto es el
vector transpuesto y multiplicamos del
lado izquierdo muy bien y entonces así
es como obtenemos la expresión
cuadrática que tenemos acá arriba verdad
y si esto a lo mejor no te resulta
familiar puedes checar el vídeo de
formas cuadráticas y en esencia esta
matriz casi es casi es la matriz que
sean la verdad excepto que todas estas
componentes tienen un medio verdad
entonces lo que podemos hacer es
factorizar afuera
digamos este valor de un medio podremos
poner este un medio y entonces ahora sí
si factor izamos un medio tenemos la
matriz cristiana de la función f
evaluada en el vector x0 verdad esto va
evaluado en el vector x0 mientras que
del lado derecho multiplica al vector
variable x
el vector constante x0 verdad y del lado
izquierdo también vamos a multiplicar
por el vector x menos x 0
x 0 y sólo que este vamos a transponer
la verdad porque va de forma horizontal
entonces esta es la formulita digamos
para los términos cuadráticas esto es lo
que captura toda la expresión de los
términos cuadráticas de nuestra función
q que teníamos originalmente verdad
entonces si juntamos todo la parte
constante en la parte lineal y la parte
cuadrática que es lo que vamos a obtener
vamos a tener que nuestra función q que
será la aproximación cuadrática y vamos
a poner un subíndice f para referirnos a
la función f
verdad y esto evaluado en x pues por un
lado será el término constante verdad
que es f evaluada en el punto x 0
más el gradiente de efe verdad aquí
vamos a expresar la parte lineal que se
escribe como el gradiente de f evaluada
evaluado en el punto x0 ya tenemos el
producto punto con el vector x menos x 0
pero verdad y finalmente agregamos la
parte cuadrática que es esta expresión
que tenemos aquí que es un medio de el
vector x menos el vector x0
pero esto por supuesto ha transpuesto
luego multiplicamos por la matriz
cristiana de la función f evaluada en el
punto perdón en el en el vector verdad
en el vector x0 verdad y finalmente
multiplicamos por x menos x 0 x menos x
x 0 entonces toda esta expresión es la
fórmula digamos vector izada de la
aproximación cuadrática de la función f
verdad esta vez ya ahora en su forma
vectorial y en realidad ahora esta
expresión no necesariamente tiene que
ser utilizada para vectores de dimensión
2 verdad con dos componentes ahora toda
esta expresión tiene sentido cuando
hablamos de tres dimensiones o cuatro o
quizás tantas variables como quieras
todo esto tiene sentido verdad por
ejemplo el gradiente de f si tuviéramos
cuatro variables entonces sería un
vector de cuatro entradas verdad si
tuviéramos la matriz gestiona entonces
ésta sería una matriz de 4x4 y además
esta forma de escribirla yo digo que es
muy muy bonita porque se parece mucho al
desarrollo en polinomios de taylor
verdad en donde teníamos para el caso
escalar verdad de una variable teníamos
una constante más la derivada de la
función evaluada en el punto por x menos
x 0 o por equis pensémoslo nada más así
más
medio de la segunda derivada de f por
equis cuadrada más o menos se veía así
verdad además creo que es más fácil
recordarlo así que en su forma digamos
desarrollada como lo teníamos al inicio
del vídeo en fin a mí me parece que todo
esto fue genial no